tomorrow New Hampshire voters will cast
their ballots in the first presidential
primary in the nation and a few them
will take care of it early when polls
open at midnight in the tiny village of
dixville notch it's one of the places
that has made midnight voting a
tradition Nikole Killion is there in New
Hampshire's north country right up there
near the Canadian border no cold good
morning so what is so special about this
place
well Tony Dixville notch is one of three
towns here in New Hampshire that votes
at midnight this year they only have
five voters each will choose from this
slate of candidates or they can write
someone in but this ritual has spent
more than half a century although this
time it almost didn't happen
buried deep in the tip of New Hampshire
the tiny hamlet of dixville notch is
known for its picturesque powder and its
power to pick presidents first 15 for 60
years the poll is opened at the stroke
of midnight
this is 1960 predominantly Republicans
here Nixon nine Kennedy zero Tom
Tillotson is the town moderator in
Dixville we take advantage of some
quirks in the New Hampshire laws that
allow us to open the polls at midnight
but this year they were on the verge of
closing because there simply weren't
enough voters who still lived there we
were down to four the town moderator
saying you know you might be the fifth
we need you that's when developer
losartan offered to move back do you
feel like you're coming in to save the
day no not really
Dixville manners because Dixville voting
at midnight is to New Hampshire what
snow is to skiing and what candidates
are to campaigning this is our museum
but Mitt Romney's father George as the
story goes he arrived here with popsicle
a 700 pound elephant to Reagan he was
just such a gentleman
and such a personable person Dole
Clinton Bush and McCain they've all been
here why is it important for the
candidates to come here to Dixville
notch in retail campaigning you know
anything I guess you can do to get an
edge Colorado Senator Michael Bennet is
the only candidate in the current
presidential field who has visited
doesn't make a difference though to have
that presence just to press the flesh
take a photo it does make a difference
but again I think we're getting a good
feeling of who the candidates are we'd
love to see him but I think we can carry
on our tradition without them being here
neither would tip their hand about who
they may vote for but I did survey some
of the other five voters and some have
made up their minds while others are
still undecided even at this late hour
gale alright Nicole thank you very much
I don't know if I want to go there to
convince that guy to go back great
tradition there